and my follow-up question would have
been that you have faced tons of
brilliant youngsters what is your take
on Vincent kymer uh
uh gukesh and pragnananda it was
sensation of what we have witnessed
during the World Cup
I think they're all very very good uh
good cash is clearly the strongest
classical player right now
um
and then
you have uh Prague and abdulsator of who
are really
strong but also mentality monsters
and then
um I think on a tier slightly below
below we have um Vincent and and a few
others but what I think is very clear is
that
just is in good hands for um for the
future
um I think
this generation of players born from
1990 to 94.
um really have dominated for for a long
time and finally now with these
with these youngsters born
uh 2003 and and after we have
survey a generation that's um that's
worthy of um successing us when the time
comes and
the time could be fairly soon
yeah